this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists ryan you ever feel like
you're too busy
um i don't know sometimes i guess yeah
don't we all
yeah today we're going to talk about the
problem
with busyness um we're talking about how
to better manage our time we're supposed
to have a
a guest here today eve could not make it
this is actually the second time she
canceled on us so um actually i think it
was like last minute
at the middle of the night right in the
darkness of night
that's right but uh totally totally
understand yeah yeah
but the reason i wanted to keep doing
this episode is because
i realized that over the last decade
11 12 years really i've become an expert
on busyness i'm an expert at very
few things but if there's one thing i
have a deep
understanding about it's
being busy and also the flip side of the
coin
not being busy i'm going to start with a
question from tim
from twitter he said why can't we ever
seem to get ahead of our to-do
lists man i think i think we're gonna
like
die with many things on a to-do list i
mean it's
it's impossible to do everything bury me
with my to-do list
it's the last checkbox on the to-do list
we should make the uh the patreon
the maximal episode that that's the
title bury me with my to-do list yeah
you know there's always stuff to do
right you know you know i don't have a
to-do list
right you have a today list i have a
today list and i also have a someday
list
i was just looking at both this morning
and here are the few things i want to
accomplish today i was looking at that
and then i moved one or two things to my
someday list and when i went into that
someday list
i went and deleted like a bunch of
things like why is this still on here i
don't want to do this someday
yeah and so it reminds me of my i have a
recommendation list
so anyone brings up anytime anyone
brings up anything
whether it's like hey you should see
this random place this random city ryan
have you considered watching porn
yeah you should go to this randy museum
you should check out this yeah this
random port
whatever it is like i'll write it down
for recommendations and i was looking at
that
and uh i have to go in there and because
like there's so many recommendations
like i will never
do every single one of those
recommendations it's like books to read
movies to see places to eat places to
visit yeah well and here's here's the
difference
if you don't feel obligated then it's
just a collection for me my someday list
is a collection
of potential things if i've run out of
things to do and want something to do
then here it's a i want to watch that
movie or i want to i want to work on
this project or work on this proposal or
whatever it might be
but i don't feel obligated and the same
with the recommendation list i have a
list similar to that it's an essay ideas
list in fact about that too on the
maximal episode today i'm going to talk
about a couple of those essay ideas that
i haven't written yet but i want to i'm
going to talk
them through with you because maybe
we'll sort of write them aloud
on the private podcast but uh the essay
list for me
is just this i don't know what's the
word sean
repository that a dumping ground
a landfill of ideas i hate ideas by the
way
ideas are the worst
and so the reason i have these sort of
notepads and other things is to like get
rid of the ideas
not to heap them onto my calendar my
obligation
list we did a episode about obligations
recently you can go back
and check that out we'll put a link to
the obligations episode
in the show notes but here's the thing
about busyness tim
why can't we get ahead of our to-do
lists well it's because
of the to-do list the to-do list isn't
the problem if you hear
i'm sorry the to-do list is the problem
it's not the the fact that you want to
do
certain things or that you have um
let me just get back let me step back
for a second the problem
is the fact that we are obligated
by our to-do list and often
what's on our to-do list ryan it's
everyone else's
expectations of us so what you're saying
is is throw out the to-do list that's
what tim should do
well i i'm i'm not if you have no to-do
list then you have no to-do list to not
complete
well maybe here's i remember i was doing
an episode of minimalism today it's this
little
solo project i've been working on i was
talking to someone she said
she talked about what her was on her
struggle list
i'm like that's fascinating way to put
it you have a struggle list what's on
your thriving list
oh i don't have one of those oh so you
have a a a thing that you struck and our
to-do list in many ways is
simply a struggle here are the things
we're going to struggle through now
what are what are the hidden to-do lists
that we have ryan
we have our email that's the number one
hidden to-do list
i was just talking to cal newport this
week he has a new book coming out called
a world without email we're gonna get
him back on the podcast to discuss that
because i'm
i'm endlessly fascinated by that because
what is email it's everyone else's to-do
list
all it's a repository of everyone else's
to-do list
thrust upon me whenever i feel the need
to check it yeah and the reason i don't
have email on my phone
is because at any moment someone else's
expectation can
totally screw up my day this happened to
me yesterday ryan
it wasn't on my phone i was checking my
email on the computer and we got a
by the way this past week is one of the
weeks where you might
i might actually say this week that
we're recording this we're recording
this on a friday
i was borderline busy for the first time
in a long time and i don't like that
and i'm going to explain the difference
between busy and focused
in a moment but i was a little bit busy
and why was i
why was i busy well it was because i let
other people's expectations
dictate my day yeah what is busyness
anyway
busyness just means that we have a bunch
of deadlines we have a bunch of things
to do
by a certain deadline now a deadline can
be
some something as simple as oh i have to
have dinner with mark at 7 p.m that's a
deadline mm-hmm isn't it
you have that on your calendar yeah um
another deadline could be oh i need to
turn in the eighth
draft of love people use things which i
turned in last night at about 11
p.m and it was 868 edits
and our publisher was really
really adamant about
finishing this on uh within a particular
timeline i wasn't able to do it in a
timeline and so what happened
i felt the extra demand of someone
else's
expectation now i welcome that into my
world that was my
fault it wasn't someone else's fault
it's
my accepting someone else's expectation
is when it makes itself on to my busy
list
which is probably a better way to
describe a to-do list yeah
for sure here's the thing about being
busy whenever i say i'm busy
i'm really saying my life is out of
control
you can tweet that podcast sean um i
just did this video it's on our youtube
channel
jordan and i have been working on this
series and i had a lot of fun with this
this might have been
your best or second best one so far it's
called let's talk about
being busy and the series is called
let's talk about less
let's talk about less baby let's talk
about you
and me we should totally come up with
this let's talk about all the things on
that to-do list let's get weird al
yankovic too
help us raise rest in peace good god
he's alive alive and well yeah so um
let's talk about being busy there's this
video and we recorded it in this
abandoned not abandoned this empty
it looked abandoned this empty office
space
and jordan did a great job with all
these background sounds of phones and
and and all the sounds of busyness
because when you think of busy what
what what images and sounds does it
conjure ryan
oh i just i think it's someone like
running around and
like you know with a cup of coffee and
it's like spilling everywhere and
yes they're yeah running from office to
office or
yeah i don't know or they're out doing a
bunch of errands because i know like
that's when i feel busy
when i when i like have to i don't know
do the dry cleaning
and wash the car and you know like let
everything
build up to like one day of these you
know things that we all have to do
and then i'm like oh like i'm busy today
with
errands okay and so what you're
describing with the guy spilling the
coffee or
or running around from place to place to
place to place is chaos
it's and so a to-do list or busyness
is really a description of chaos when i
say my life is out of control
when i'm busy well what's the
alternative
it's to be focused and really that's
what the video the let's talk about
being busy video is about let's put a
link to that in the show note sean
so people can check it out but
fundamentally the thesis of that is
henry david thoreau said it's not enough
to be busy the question is what are you
busy about that's a paraphrase it's not
an exact quote
but if i were to open that message i
would basically say it's not enough to
be busy the question is what are you
focused on
because i most of the time i'm very
focused
whether it's writing or recording a
podcast we're very focused right now
i don't feel busy right now i really
enjoy doing these podcasts especially
when it's just
me and you without a guest yeah i i
enjoy those a lot it doesn't feel busy
to me although it apes the form of
busyness because
i'm doing something yeah but here's the
difference
i don't have to do this i
get to do this you're busy only when you
have to do a bunch of things
yeah the car wash thing that you just
said didn't resonate with me because
i really enjoy getting my car washed
yeah like ironing
ironing is great i ironed a shirt two
days ago right just for fun
yeah yeah it wasn't even wrinkled it
wasn't even my shirt it was a random
person i stole their shirt
i took it home iron it gave it back to
them yeah it was really nice
it's funny you said something so yeah so
like this apes the form of busy but then
you know busy apes the form of
productivity right oh like yeah busyness
apes the form of
uh yeah a productivity obviously we'll
talk about productivity on the maximum
we got some great questions
to answer because ryan you're absolutely
right the productivity thing the
efficiency thing we're going to talk
about those what are some of the
differences
as well but on this minimal episode i
really want to get into a few of the
questions we have here the first one
is from sherry in los angeles we talk
about minimalism in terms of having less
things but what about
having less to do in terms of having
more time
what do you suggest in terms of
freeing up time so that we
so that people feel they have a more
balanced lifestyle
that brings them purpose and joy so
sherry brings up a good point we're
talking about minimalism we often talk
about
the stuff right the decluttering
but today we're kind of talking about
decluttering our calendars in a way
yeah but i want to do so in a
non-prescriptive way although we can
talk about some of the how
to's and i think fundamentally
they can help in terms of time
management
but i also don't think we have a problem
with
well if i just get seven more tools now
all of a sudden i'm going to
manage my time better
she talks about having less stuff but
then also wanting to have
less to do because she wants what more
more time that's why i was really
interested in minimalism
right because our lives were so full of
busy
into dues that we were out of control
and now that you've gotten rid of the
excess stuff ryan actually has more time
he has about
43 hours a day now right
but the weird thing is it can feel that
way sometimes sure
because time is is this weird thing of
course we have only the same 24 hours a
day so no i can't give you more time
in a day yeah so that's not what you
mean how do i of course not yeah no it's
it's i have more
time to uh focus on the things i want to
focus on
exactly or maybe it's more time to
uh relax or meditate whatever it is
but yeah i mean when you and it's funny
because it starts off
like when we were working in the
corporate world it started off with
doing like a 40 hour a week job 8 hours
a day for 5 days and then you get
promoted
and then you're like oh ok maybe i'm
going to work 9 or 10 hours
and then you get promoted again and now
you respond you know then i was
responsible for other people
so then uh you know you have to start
saying yes to everything
and then in the retail world you have to
be available from when the stores open
to when the stores close
so it's like this slow progression of
saying yes to everything and and taking
advantage of
every promotion that gets thrown in
front of you and then you end up
overworked and that's when we start
asking well that what
sherry was asking we start asking
ourselves about work-life balance
yeah but again we've talked about this
last couple podcasts about there is no
such thing
like you're overworked right we hear
that a lot no one ever calls in and
they're like you know what i am over
lifed right and i really need to figure
out this work-life balance thing
so when someone asks about work-life
balance i hear them
saying hey i'm overworked and i need to
figure out how to get more life and less
work
yes and even if it's not work work in
the sense of vocation it's all these
other things we
associate with the chaos that you
mentioned earlier whether it's the
car cleaning or the ironing or doing the
laundry or cleaning the house or
taking the kids to school or packing the
lunches or whatever it might be
you have some of the busiest people i
know are stay-at-home moms
right because um it they're forced to
have
other people's these people that they
produced but there's still other people
they have their obligations on their
plate and so
they're saying yes to everything as you
just said
but even for the stay-at-home mom i've
talked to bex about this
uh beck's is a stay-at-home mom but she
also works from home as well so there's
a hybrid sort of
thing going on there but
we don't have to say yes to everything
that our kids demand of us
either right and i think we say yes to
everything why
well because we're afraid we say yes to
everything that's all busyness really is
is saying yes to too many things we
don't want to let people down it's funny
this makes me think about all the
surprise questions we have
a lot of them have to do with
in one way or another other people's
expectations yes
and so yeah when we say yes to
everything
we kind of hurt ourselves
but you know we're we're going to be
there for someone and we're not going to
let them down
well you know if you focus on not
letting everyone in your life down you
start to let yourself down
oh you could tweet that podcast sean
well you might want to reword that a
little bit and
and tweet it sean he'll make it pretty
for you thank you so much so the saying
yes
to everything is what fills our days and
then what do we do we start looking for
what
tools and methods
to fix our busy lives
you just have to get you just have to
get the perfect calendar
right a perfect calendar app i'm sorry
but a franklin planner is not going to
fix
your busy life podcast sean i apologize
he still uses the franklin planner
i love it um yeah and by the way it's
not that those things are wrong or using
i use the calendar on
my phone i use google calendar or
whatever like those things are
fine but it's quixotic to think that
adding more is going to help us do
less yeah the blackberry remember when
we brought the blackberry into our
corporate lives
it was supposed to save us one to two
hours a day well what it really did was
it put me on call like a doctor yeah and
i wasn't saving any time
but i was trying to pretend like i was
saving people's lives or something
because
i was constantly glued to that
productivity machine
well it's funny yeah i used to like tell
people it saves you an hour a day or two
hours a day because
you know while you're in the waiting
room at the doctor's office you know you
got to wait there for 30 minutes you
could catch up on some work
but you're right like if anything it's
adding time to your day it's not taking
away
so the fear thing right i want to get
back to that because we're saying yes to
everything because we
fear something like you said we don't
want to let other people down what what
is the fear behind that
the fear is well i'm the fear i fear
losing
love or friendship or i i fear that i
i projected this image this identity of
myself
and i fear i can't live up to it and
what will that
mean if the rest of the world perceives
me in a way different
from the way i've projected to the world
well that just means i've been lying to
the world if i've put together this
image
of the infallible highly productive
human
the well-balanced man or woman
then i was lying to the world
and why was i lying to the world it
wasn't intentional it's because i was
lying to myself
yeah we lie to ourselves when they say i
can get all of these things done
how else do we lie to ourselves we lie
to ourselves because we say
once i get these things done then i'll
be
happy if i just get the to-do list
complete
well then i'll be more complete myself
like i said this week had been a bit
quote busy for me
because i was focused on a few too many
things too many other people's
expectations i'll give you an example
one is we're moving to a new studio
space so i've been negotiating a lease
with a realtor and a landlord i went all
over the place looking for a new studio
space for us
found us a great spot doing a
negotiation with them this week that
took a lot of time reading over
contracts and
and asking for a specific price etc
so that back and forth was yeah a little
bit of
uh uh commitment right it took it took
some time
by itself totally fine not a big deal
didn't fill up my calendar really
right but then you you lump in the
publisher comes back to me at the same
time and they're like
well um we need this back by
this date and i'm like well i can't ever
do it by this day how about this date
and they're like
i don't know i'm like i don't even know
if i can get it done by that day and so
i'm letting all of a sudden now someone
else's expectation is
hey can you review this lease and can
you
go over this new draft of the book with
868 changes in it and it's like okay i
can
i think i can do these two things oh but
then ryan i have a speaking gig
okay and then we have this other thing
yeah and it's like well wait a minute
i've said yes to a lot of things that
it's okay to say yes to
but it may be a protracted time frame
yeah
because all of these things on their own
so to quote derek sivers were hell yeahs
yes because derek sivers is hell yeah or
no right put a link to that uh blog post
in the show notes please sean
i mean if you want to really understand
your priorities
it's hell yeah or no and most of the
things on our to-do list are
just or yeah i guess
it doesn't make it to my to-do list if
it's a yeah i guess yeah
and then so we had quite a few things
going on and we had someone
literally at 11 59 p.m cancel on our
podcast and it's like
oh no do i we have to figure out how to
do podcast show notes within a
a three hour yeah and so like it was
just too much
and so we step back and say well what am
i afraid of here yeah
if i say well this is gonna have to wait
a week that's gonna have to wait a month
i'm gonna have to say no to this what am
i afraid of
no new tools are gonna help me
with that no only thing that's really
gonna help me is
understanding that it's been frantic for
40 years
and it will continue to be frantic
because of the to-do list
not because i'm better managing it with
the appropriate calendars and apps and
phones and devices and and tablets
those things they complicate literally
right they
they complect our lives they interweave
more complexity into our life what does
that do it just makes us
more busy now i love what you said about
work-life balance ryan
because right after she said work-life
balance she said living a life with more
purpose
and joy we never asked for more joy
peace balance right like
uh you know i just have a little bit too
much joy this week and so maybe i could
extend that to next week well no it's
the to-do list that is getting in the
way of the joy
yeah all the things that are on the
to-do list you are complete without them
yeah
and so those things whether they're
physical things or the things on your
calendar
i want them to enhance augment amplify
my experience of life i really enjoy
doing these podcasts with you
they enhance my life i don't have to do
this though
i get to do this yeah absolutely and
that's a wonderful place
to be yeah but yeah sherry if you want
to minimize
your to-do list you've got to say no
more and some
you know it's it's funny because i don't
know which is harder to tell yourself no
like when i think about how uh i play
guitar
i you know do some like spanish classes
uh i like to write music
uh i play saxophone i can't do it all at
once
so like i have to tell myself i have to
be honest with myself
and be like oh it's okay that i enjoy
these hobbies
but i'm not gonna be a professional
saxophone player i'm not going to
you know speak the best spanish
so i'm telling myself no in the sense of
i'm accepting my own limitations
uh but i can still dabble with those
things when i have time to do that and
that's okay
where i think sometimes we
we don't tell ourselves no and we kind
of take on too much
and then you add to that other people's
expectations and to do's that they want
you to do
it's hard to tell them no but yeah it's
like it's funny because i can see where
i don't
i can see where it would be harder to
tell yourself no than it would be
other people know well because everyone
you know and it's gonna be a hard pill
to swallow
everyone you know expects something from
you
sure they have expectations and
you are not obligated you're not
responsible
there is no responsibility for their
expectations
you know what i say yes to aggressively
ryan i say yes a lot to something
i say yes to an empty calendar and so
it's not just me saying no
to you or if someone invites me over for
dinner or whatever
i usually am saying yes to having
nothing
on my calendar because an empty calendar
is real freedom and i think you can
tweet that podcast sean
so it's a good one because what is that
really my what's on my calendar
or my hell yeah and my hell yeahs are my
priorities
and speaking of priorities sherry i'm
gonna send you a copy of our book
essential
it's an essay collection that ryan and i
wrote it's 150 different essays
about intentional living there's 12
different areas of intentional living
two of those chapters so it's 12
different different chapters two of the
chapters i think will really stand out
to you sherry there's a success chapter
which we talk about redefining
success but more importantly the
priorities chapter in
essential so if you like our podcast we
think you'll enjoy
the audiobook version of essential
essays by the minimalists or if you want
the book book or the ebook we're happy
to send those to you
as well ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for our
lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed did you know
those texts go to both of our phones and
we even dip in there and
respond to people personally we respond
to some folks
on the podcast as well now during the
lightning round this is where ryan and i
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response
we call them minimal maxims by the way
you can find all of our minimal maxims
in the show notes
or over at minimalmaxims.com adam
sutherland has a question for us
what can someone do if they feel they're
too busy
to figure out how to become less busy
now this there's a freudian slip here
in this question right because really
what the question i think he's positing
is
uh when he says what can someone do to
become less busy
is really what he means well yeah but
but he's saying they're too busy to
figure
out how to become less busy right like
they don't have enough time
to figure out how to become less busy
let me give you a pithy answer maybe we
can unpack it ryan
we are too busy only because we don't
understand
why we are busy yeah
so totally agree i think quite often we
never even stop to consider
less with respect to our stuff our
physical possessions
but our calendars our business in our
society is what it's a status symbol
it is the new bmw is being busy
who was the guy the ceo 30 years old and
he was like
they wrote this whole article on him i
forget what magazine but he was bragging
about
essentially working 20 hours a day
getting four hours
i wrote an essay about him aaron levi i
think his name is i wonder how he's
doing these days
yeah i don't know my guess clearly that
wasn't sustainable so
you know hopefully he he steered out of
the chaos right
yeah and maybe he's superhuman who knows
no he's not and that's the thing right
the
and by the way he's not even human right
because that
all of that stuff that's not how humans
behave
we didn't evolve over the last 200 to
300
000 years to have full calendars full of
notifications and yeah and and tweets
and
i mean i went through the whole thing on
that video with jordan the let's talk
about
being busy video you did a great job
with those graphics really making even
the screen busy
the noise was busy the telephone's
ringing the fax machine's going whatever
was going on the crowd the noise
the chaos and his life was filled with
cows we didn't evolve for that kind of
chaos
and so we did evolve to to fear
real danger so if you're going to get
eaten by an apex predator
but now our calendar has turned into the
biggest apex
predator in our lives and of course so
we're running away from our calendars
yeah
and in fact we are too busy to figure
out how to become
less busy i have one more pithy thing
for you ryan
we are too busy because we have too much
time ooh
can i talk about that i mean we all have
the same amount of time but i guess my
42 hours in a day is too much time
here's what i mean yeah what do you mean
the average lifespan you're going to
live to about 80
right and live to 150 josh let's assume
you live
at the average length of a person you're
gonna live to about 80 you're halfway
there right now
right okay but let's say that we cut
your lifespan in half
no i'll be dead today well no you'd be
dead in about six months
okay would you be doing all the same
busy chaotic things
if you had only six months left or what
if what if we had only 20 or 25 years on
on this earth
would we be filling our lives no what we
do is because we
think we're going to live to 80 that's
so far off to us
it's functionally infinite right it's
this hypothetical
future by the way it all happened so
fast i'll be 40 this year
and i remember being three
it was not that long ago and and so
it just happens so fast but we have so
much time because we have so much it's
like if you had
unlimited money you would waste it right
we often think we have unlimited time so
we are too busy because we have too much
time going back to my previous pithy
answer here we don't understand why we
are busy
you understand how you are busy you
understand what you're busy with you
understand who you're busy with but you
there's a good chance you understand why
you're busy you're busy because you're
afraid
to slow down my pithy answer is this
busy is an excuse not a lifestyle
i love that so adam you know
it sounds like you have a busy lifestyle
or you're pretending that you have a
busy lifestyle
and i would just challenge you and say
you know look in the mirror and
and you know be honest with yourself and
kind of see that you're really using it
as an excuse
which is okay we're not we're not here
to busy shame anyone
we're just here to get to the truth
indeed well we do have a bunch more to
talk about ryan i think i have my
favorite right here right now
segment that we've ever done on this
podcast coming up i'm truly excited
to discuss this right here right now but
first
but first here are some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
check them out
hi minimalist this is beth from chicago
and i was calling in
with a tip this could be for clothing
but also
anything else and i'll explain so when
it comes to clothing
my rule is this if i would rather go in
to my hamper and re-wear a piece of item
that's dirty
then get a like item out of the closet
so maybe it's a pair of jeans
then it's time for the jeans in the
closet to go so maybe that means just
buying three pairs of my favorite one
then get rid of the rest and that's good
with me
so how that applies to other things so
maybe um
items like shampoo if you get done with
the bottle and you'd go out and
buy that same one again rather than
using all the other half used ones in
your closet
time to go and same with maybe a pot or
a pan if that one breaks and you're
going to go out and re-buy that same one
instead of using ones that you already
have that are the similar size
then it's time for those ones to go as
well hi
this is molly from salt lake city i'm
calling the tip regarding managing
the collecting impulse one strategy i
have used is to make friends with
people who share the same hobby or
collection
and do regular exchanges with them so
you get the thrill of having a new item
but then when the throw wears off you
just return it to the
other owner and you can get another new
item when you give it back
and anyway thank you and have a nice day
all right y'all thanks again to our
special guest we're sponsored this week
by water
drink it today actually we're sponsored
by you
so thank you if you are one of our
supporters yeah there are
6 000 or so of you and we're really
grateful for your support ryan for our
added value
this week speaking of people pretending
to be busy
which is by the way all we're all really
doing none of us are saving the world
if you are you're probably not listening
to this podcast
it's okay let's admit let's submit the
truth here
but let we often pretend that we're
being busy so my added value this week
in fact this is your homework for
everyone listening to this i want you to
go
watch fake famous it's on hbo it's a
documentary
and they take this guy this new york
times reporter takes three people who
they just put an ad out says do you want
to be famous and they
interview a bunch of people and they
find three people and they help
them become fake famous on instagram
oh wow and i'm not gonna give it away
because there are
some twists and it's only about an hour
so long it's a great
illustration of well what an influencer
really is in fact i want to do a the
reason it's a homework assignment for
you listening to this
is i want to do a whole podcast episode
about
influencers i want to be an outfluencer
uh so so the the influencer thing is
fascinating because really what
influencers are you learn this in this
film
influencer is just a fancy new word to
say
infomercial spokesperson what do you
think about influencers that's because
they're not influential
and by the way there's this measurement
of influence i'll we'll talk about when
we do an episode about it but fake
famous on hbo phenomenal documentary i
can't wait to check this out
you'll really enjoy it because it shows
well it shows
the the facade
what the the crumbling
of everything behind the facade of
fame i have to put it on my to watch
list
as long as you put on your to-do list
real quick for right here right now
here's the thing i'm excited about ryan
here's one thing that's going on
in the life of the minimalists oh yeah
uh two days ago i signed up for
clubhouse oh man you're so cool and hip
well you're on clubhouse and i didn't
know here's the thing i
and i didn't have an invite i couldn't
get an invite i'm like how do i get an
invite texting
you should have told me you were on
clubhouse come on sean we had this
you were here when we were talking about
it i told you i was on there it doesn't
matter i'm glad you're on it now i've
i've done a couple
actually that's not true i've done one
room and it was
uh part of the men's team thing that i'm
part of it was
this man who has his own men's team
going on and he
was like hey will you join me for this
discussion with this circle of men
about uh commitments and it was good it
was fun
i love it how it's audio only
um because i was like literally making
coffee and like muting myself as we were
talking
yeah um which is yeah it's kind of cool
to be able to like i don't know i feel
like i
have better conversations when i can
pace so yeah it's really good it's it's
a pretty cool platform so
i don't know exactly what i want to use
it for yes
um and i haven't gone on there even to
really go into other rooms and see what
other people are using it for i've only
been on when people invite me so what
are you
excited to use it for i love that
question what am i
because i am more excited about this app
than i'm as excited about this as i was
about twitter in 2008 when i joined
twitter
because i and by the way i think this
will be one of the biggest
social media apps in the world soon it's
it's invite only currently
by the time this comes out i don't even
know if it's available for android
phones yet
and and so people are asking me like
well how do i how do i find it or
they're tweeting me what is clubhouse
i'm like
i'm not google you can google like what
is clubhouse right
but it is the way i can describe it is
it is an audio only
platform it sort of augments podcasts
the way twitter augments blogs it is to
podcast what twitter was to blogs
a decade and a half ago interesting yeah
it's to me i would describe it as
a live stream audio only service
yeah so this is before our time but old
party lines where people
when you were when you had a home phone
a landline phone in your house and there
are two of them you could listen on like
your dad's conversations when you were
growing up and they could sneak in
this is something i never did that but
you didn't you could yeah
yeah my dad was not talking about
anything interesting oh that's probably
true you could sneak in on your mom's
conversation she was definitely talking
about
everything it was me and the cops
listening
yeah i do kind of feel that way like i'm
listening in to some conversations where
i
maybe shouldn't be listening sometimes
it feels that way anyway
it's like this old this party line so
you can have a bunch of people in a room
or you can have really small rooms
and it's it's simultaneously synchronous
and asynchronous synchronous means you
and i speaking like on the phone
together right yeah but it's
asynchronous because you can you and i
can speak on the phone together
in different locations but in front of a
large audience right so it could be me
and you and joshua becker and jordan no
more and jess ness williams and courtney
carver all in one room
speaking the five of us yeah but then we
could have 5 000 people
listening as well at the same time yeah
it makes me uh it makes me think of our
quarantined conversations and how it's
like a live quarantine conversation when
we when we were doing our quality
conversations what are we calling them
now
uh well yeah they're they were quality
yeah quality conversations 50 of those
over on our patreon yeah no it's a it's
a it's a unique app i will say
the like uh when i got off that phone
call
mm-hmm or is it a phone call whatever
that clubhouse
chat room whatever you want to call it
when i exited out of there i just
briefly went through
to see what people were using it for
just to see the names of the rooms
and it just cracks me up because like
half of them like at least when i was on
there it was
all like how to grow your instagram
following how to grow your
how to you know i don't care about
anything yeah i know it's nonsense so
there's a but
there's going to be because there are no
gatekeepers yeah of course it's going to
be nonsense yeah right
but it just seems like it's a lot of uh
yeah there's some
quality stuff on what just like anything
else right without gatekeepers like this
half of its quality the other half of it
you're like
what here listen to me and i'll show you
how to grow your audience with whatever
yeah yeah so you curate the people you
follow here's
there's one there's one reason i joined
is kapil goop to join
and so he did a room last night and bex
and i were in there find them on there
because in a different state you know
she's up in montana right now but her
and i were like
connecting through this like because
we're listening to kapil he's in there
by himself
he's not communicating with any he's
just talking to the air
and there are hundreds of people
listening and
i mean it was the only thing the way i
described the bex was inspirational fire
and brimstone
it's like inspirational armageddon in a
way the
things he talks about in fact i'm gonna
read one of his essays on the maximal
episode today
or this week uh this thursday but i um
i was listening to him and then he
hopped into another room and
he was letting some venture capitalists
ask him questions
and i stayed up till 11 o'clock last
night listening
to him you know i go to bed at eight
yeah but i was on
because here's the thing about this this
is like appointment television
and here's what this was exciting to me
because these aren't recorded they're
i love the ephemeral nature of it once
you've done it
it's like a phone call if i call you on
the phone and and
sean was supposed to be a three-way
conversation between me and sean and you
yeah but sean didn't join he can't be
like hey can you go ahead and send me
that phone call
no it's gone right and i i really enjoy
that about this
remember back in the days we had
appointment viewing the sopranos come on
sunday at 9 00 p.m
and you had to you waited all week for
that yeah and so and then last night it
was sam harris and kapil group that had
rooms at the same time and i was like
well who do i choose from now for me
it's a no-brainer i would choose kapil
gupta over anyone in the world
um and he he
had this it was just an amazing
experience and i got
goosebumps i haven't had that from a
social media app
this is real social media
and so um i'm going to do and hopefully
ryan will join me for this we're doing
uh
we're going to be together that day so
but even if we're not that's the
beautiful thing about clubhouse
on sunday 3 21 that's march 21st by the
way
three two one is my favorite date i like
it
three two one yes very uh very ocd 6 p.m
on march
21st on clubhouse uh now you have to
find a way to get on clubhouse you can
figure it out if you want to be there if
you have a deep desire to be on
clubhouse
you will figure it out you know we're
just going to get a bunch of tweets
asking for invites
right well i mean i only have like one
or two left so you i can give you one
yeah exactly yeah so i'm just prefacing
with people listening to this like
yeah you are limited to only so many
invites and
if you invite like if i invited you and
you didn't accept the invite it won't
let you do another invite
right like you can only yeah yeah and so
we'll be on there
i will probably invite some other folks
on to talk as well
i like that you can invite people on
they can ask a question and they can go
back to listening
in the audience i've just really enjoyed
it so far because
there are some there's some deep
meaningful conversations
like you said there's some nonsense on
there i'm not gonna browse i'm not gonna
hop on there and browse yeah there's
nonsense on instagram i mean it's
no matter what platform you go to so
what are we talking about on march 21st
sunday we're going to have a
conversation
about well we're going to maneuver a
little bit
we're obviously going to talk about
minimalism but we're going to
we're going to talk about the
understanding behind the letting go
and so i found this this forum
this place is best suited
for deep conversations and so i follow a
well-curated list of people
who have conversations they often
disagree with each other i was listening
to another one
last night as i was going through
editing some of the pictures that jordan
took and i was just sort of selecting
some photos and listening
and i was listening to some people argue
and i was like oh this is
this is really fast because they were
arguing but in a way that was respectful
and you would never get that elsewhere
because of the real-time nature and the
ephemeral nature the appointment viewing
nature
the live nature of it you can't comment
on it can you
like if you're a listener there's no
like chat room there's no text
like you're literally just on there
listening to other people and if they
want to bring you on they can like send
you an invite but other than that i mean
there's no
way for the people listening to interact
with each other right there's there's
it's tech there's no text it's no video
it's audio only you see a picture of the
person speaking
and it's remove the barrier of entry
because like to do a podcast like this
we
have a talented producer talented
filmmaker we have
expensive microphones but with this it's
just your iphone
and the conversation is really the
the center yeah and so march 21st 6 p.m
pacific
march 21st 6 p.m pacific join us on
clubhouse
we're going to talk about the deep
understanding
behind letting go
we've got a bunch more surprise
questions this week ryan like
what are the five main reasons everyone
is so busy all the time
if you're overwhelmed how do you ask
friends and co-workers to give
you space what is the difference between
being busy and being productive
what should i be doing when i have
nothing to do i love that question
plus a million more questions for the
minimalist and if you want to hear all
that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week that's right
we release a private podcast episode
every thursday over on patreon visit the
minimalists.com support to subscribe and
get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app it's cheaper than a cup of coffee
and it keeps our show 100
advertisement free you can follow the
minimalist on facebook twitter and
instagram
at the minimalist sign up for our email
list over at theminimalists.com if you
want our
show notes in your inbox you'll also
receive our simple sunday minimalist
writings
for free whenever we send those if you
have a question comment or minimalism
tip for our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com and if you leave here
today with one message
we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it